Kim Kardashian weighs in on north and
Saints sibling rivalry
[Music]
in August the reality star opened up
about a mini beef between her
four-year-old daughter and one-year-old
son I mean hello while filling in for
Kelly Ripa on live with Kelly and Ryan I
thought it was a phase it was like okay
a couple months like you know she's just
warming up to it she's get so jealous
you know when I would breastfeed and all
that kind of stuff and now I just the
phase isn't going away but now the 36
year old who is expecting her third
child via surrogate I'm so excited about
it
is setting the record straight perfect
playing a game of facts with her grandma
MJ so I just kind of want to know like
what you know in the video posted to her
app Kim shuts down tabloid headlines
we're the biggest target ever including
one titled monster mom Kim says North
does not like her brother st. so I'm
sorry to me the social media maven
explains quote obviously North loved st.
she just is still jealous she needs to
still get it together and warm up and
like be a little bit nicer but I think
she is getting there
I saw glimmers of hope like a week ago
adding she's not like hurting him or
anything she just doesn't want boys in a
room she's crazy
[Music]
you